- It's a real swoop, huh?
(even tempo music)
- Don't you always have bangs, in a way?
- They're there to hide foreheads.
- I routinely do weird
things with my hair.
I bleached a stripe.
Had a weird rattail.
Had a mullet.
If I like it,
I could
see myself getting bangs.
- I'm gonna feel self-conscious
a little bit more than I normally would.
- Today I'm running an event for
a pretty
high profile client.
We've never interacted face to face.
Having bangs in a professional setting
that's a little dicey for me.
- I've got plenty other things
to be self-conscious about.
I feel like hair is way down the list.
(rock music)
(laughs)
- My fuckin' God.
I feel like a caveman.
(laughs)
- Huh.
Interesting.
(laughs)
- Uh, ooh.
- When do I make my 1974
dating videotape?
Hello Ladies.
My name is Daniel.
I'm in sales.
I like fine Italian cusine.
- It's 1960's rock guy, but like,
in a shitty band.
- A Viking that gets left behind.
- Vice principal.
- I don't know if I like it or I hate it.
It feels real heavy up here.
- It's like, kinda highlighting my eyes.
- Not really.
- Man, I hope I don't
pass out from the heat.
(rock music)
- [Mike] Okay, open.
(laughs)
- Nice.
- [Mike] Yes.
- Cool.
Well my first official interaction with
a human being wearing this.
The guys was about as dismissive
as humanly possible, I guess.
- Just bangin' it up on a bicycle.
- [Mike] Do you think I
could keep these bangs?
- I mean, you could.
- [Mike] Did you notice
anything different?
- You're holding your phone.
- I asked my wife what she would do
if I came home like this.
She did say that if I did do it
I should go get it done professionally.
Which I don't think is
a slam on you, Jordan.
But, you know, don't quit your day job.
- [Mike] Guys, how're my bangs doin?
- [Man] They're bangin'.
- They're bangin. I got
bangin' bangs today.
Jarred, do you notice
anything different about me?
- The horrible wig that you're wearing.
I really don't think that you
should ever do this again.
- I just dealt with my client
and they felt like I was just
a hippie guy doin' business.
Feeling very self conscious about that.
You said you actually
kinda liked 'em though.
- I did.
- Is that just you being
afraid to insult me?
- It mighta been.
(laughs)
- I just ran into a guy
I hadn't seen in months.
And he did not notice a
thing different about me.
So does that mean that I'm the guy
that does this sort of thing
often enough that nobody notices?
I feel like I'm learnin' more about myself
than you guys are learnin' about bangs.
- The first person I showed
gave me some positive feedback.
The more people I was showing,
they were like making fun of me basically.
- There was some visibility problems.
I also noticed the bangs are kinda sweaty.
- The bangs got in my eyes
less than my current hair does.
- I couldn't tell if people
were looking at me
more different than they normally would.
I was kinda paranoid about that.
- I'm meeting people for the first time
that I've had a lot of
emails exchange with.
And the guy's like, "Oh, wow.
"So you're a real business man.
"And you look like some hippie guy."
- These people are never
gonna call me back.
- I thought my confidence
would be effected.
And it ended up not being the case.
- Some people don't like it.
As long as you like it,
that's all that matters.
Ah.
(country music)